everyone it is friday and time for
what's trending this morning and we have
the
lovely mercedes martinez joining us live
from the mix 94.1
studio good morning mercedes how about
the nights last night
oh my gosh you know they are trending
this morning alex they beat the saint
louis blues yesterday
in their second game of round robin play
what an exciting game the score was six
to four in the blues
they took the lead in the first period
with former golden knight david perron
scoring that oh that was a dagger to the
heart
well they woke up in the second period
with goals from shea theodore
and two from alex tuck before st louis
scored
back to back pulling ahead of the
knights four to three
well that third period was huge for the
golden knights with
goals from zach white cloud his first
mark stone another from
theodore and the final game of round
robin play is
saturday versus the colorado avalanche
and the winner
they're gonna get the number one seed
from the western conference
go knights go mercedes we were talking
about my issues with watching the games
i have depended on your tweets in part
to know what's going on so thank you for
those
[Laughter]
i love that well also trending going to
another sport a league of their own is
trending remember there's no crying in
baseball that movie
amazon series adaptation of the 1992
penny marshall film has been given
the green light now this hour-long
series
it's going to tell the story of an
entire generation of women
who dreamed of playing professional
baseball the co-head of television for
amazon studios says
that they've taken a classic movie they
reimagined it for a new generation with
new characters
and the show was co-created by broad
city's abby jacobson and she's gonna
also star in the series
and then also trending this morning is
halloween it's hard to believe that it's
less than three months away
but it looks like according to finance
experts they forecast that we could see
quite the dip
in sales this year a lot of halloween
get-togethers and events are being
canceled or
altered due to covet 19. so
fingers crossed the kids can still
trick-or-treat but i guess we're going
to have to wait and see
and that's what's trending thanks alex
thanks mercedes i know you got to get
back on the radio so we'll let you go
we appreciate it have a great weekend
and catch mercedes on 94.1 this morning
take care
bye